chin joining us now Iraq war veteran I'm
delighted he's with us Chris nuit and
Walid Phares of course and Don Bremer
former Intel officer Iraq war veteran
gentlemen great to see you tonight we
always pray for our troops in harm's way
on nights like tonight and it's serious
time every time we use military force
overseas well let's get your sense on
this we're talking a little earlier
about Syria like Iraq extremely
complicated place I think we in America
we think we think of the Middle East all
is one place that's not and it's it's
the exact opposite of that it's like a
hundred places
tell us about Syria on the ground in
your view of what happened tonight what
happened tonight Laura what I know okay
I can see is that this is not a u.s.
Syria operation this is not the invasion
of Iraq this is not the invasion of
Afghanistan for those who are debating
and getting very warm about this issue
this is a very specific strike against
the Assad regime capacities to deliver
chemical weapons now we cannot judge
tonight if the Syrian regime decides to
stop using it operation is over if there
are reactions which I anticipate not
necessarily in Damascus but other parts
of Syria where we have assets it's a
different story
Don I would have to agree and you know
we did three precision attacks with a
facilities that are sarin gas which has
a very high density and a very low burn
off right so I think if Assad and his
folks act out and they take this at the
message it wasn't meant to be then this
could resolve itself rather quick
Optimus Lee I don't think so I think
that Assad will react and then we'll see
what happens tomorrow morning Chris is
former Intel officer you're so young how
can you be a former Intel officer but
you know we apparently we hit a number
of storage facilities my question is if
we knew the storage that this might be a
really dumb question but if you know the
storage facilities are there and we
thought well they had destroyed the
weapons previously we we launched our
strikes against the airfield last year
why didn't we do a preemptive strike why
did why did we wait until they used the
weapons and 40 people were killed and
more badly badly injured apparently
tonight still in hospitals that's a
great question there was for military
police Don's the
close enough we learned a lot from being
around him but I think that you we
looked at the multilateral approach and
the due diligence of having those walk
ups and the the Intel gathering now and
having all those allies we've looked at
this for a few days we know what this is
and they've had plenty of opportunities
so right now with the quantity of the
strike has increased so we're hitting
those facilities designed to prevent
those aerial ships from doing this again
and those planes from watching so we're
trying to hit him hard enough where he
stops doing this do we think that Europe
is really with us I mean it was I wish
we talked about this earlier and
Sebastian got kind of a you know angry
but my question is a simple one we have
an international consensus against the
use of chemical weapons sarin gas I mean
I don't think can we think of a time in
world history where sarin gas and
chlorine were used at the same time I
don't think so weird that's just weird
so we have an international consensus
you can't use this can't do it I've got
children dying these videos horrific the
president spoke to that clearly where is
the international community where is the
money help where's the military help why
is it that the United States has to
carry the load for everyone when the
United States has a huge debt level and
again Sebastian was like are you saying
that we don't have a moral duty I'm not
saying we don't have a moral duty but we
have a moral duty to like the next
generation and the generation after that
that we don't hand them a country that
is completely empty a financial future
that so I'm concerned about that as the
international consensus is clearly
supposedly developed
waleed Laura the consensus for tonight
we saw the United States France and
England acting together this is great
this is emotionally even great but it's
only for tonight because if you want to
go further against the regime you'll be
going against Hezbollah you will be
going against Iran and who is pressuring
us not to change our policy regarding
Iran to Europeans so there are with us
against the chemical weapons but if we
tell them we're gonna put serious
pressure on Iran which is the problem
which is the real problem Chile problem
oh no we can't you know with you against
Iran we're gonna lose it
deal and this is where it becomes very
complicated let me take us to one other
area in Syria we have 2,000 troops in
the northeastern part of Syria those
troops are now surrounded if you want
strategically by the Iranians by
Hezbollah by Assad my concern is what's
the follow-up what is the status quo for
these troops because now that we have
administered one strike I'm really eager
to know if they're gonna vivir the enemy
is gonna strike back against our troops
that's the biggest question of the night
for me
Don mattis just a few days ago according
to the New York Times description of his
mindset defense secretary Jim mattis is
trying to slow the rush to a military
strike in part because despite what MS
Hayley nikki Haley said we have the
fullscreen guys he feels he needs more
evidence to corroborate that President
Bashar al-assad's regime was responsible
for the deaths mr. Madison also said to
be concerned that a bombing campaign
could lead to a wider conflict with mr.
Assad's two main defenders Russia and
Iran now that was I guess just yesterday
that's two days ago a lot was apparently
determined and confirmed over the last
24 hours
but I don't know just body language
reading him do you think he seemed 100%
confident about what we saw tonight I
mean to me like I need to see mattis
when he's like all in game or just my
body language that could be totally
wrong but he just he seemed like you
know he was you know he's not saying
he's not for it but I don't know it just
seems like Madison's worried he's a
warrior you guys are warriors absolutely
as a warrior you know what war is like I
think he has limited as this was right I
think he had a lot on his table tonight
you know heeds there's been a lot of
speculation today you heard reports
coming out of Syria and Russia that we
that this was all a result of doings of
the UK a British planet at all yeah you
bet
so there's mixed stories coming out
Madison said you know we want to move
this slow we don't want to really go
full head to head with Russia so I think
that's why we had the attacks we did
tonight where there were three precise
hits so we did it at a time 383 m in the
morning about where we mitigated any
risk of civilian casualties
most people are away they were you know
smart bombs that went in there right for
us I think we did it right but
in general he's you know he's been
around us all of his life anytime that
you had the situation where you gonna
send troops into war that you're gonna
think about it and that's gonna lay
heavy on your heart I think he doesn't
want to be the guy that brings people in
all right guys thanks so much